on Prime crime
a seemingly freak event oh my God
I had a little Shake becomes a
years-long search for a killer we didn't
even see it coming we had to let a wolf
into our family and not even known it
[Music]
hi there everybody I'm Jesse Weber and
welcome to Prime crime this is where we
break down the most high profile and
memorable True Crime cases back in the
summer of 2017 a web of money lies and
death is about to fall in the lap of
Missouri investigators and where this
case begins is as surprising as where it
ends
it's the afternoon of June 8 2017.
police receive a call from a snake
breeding facility just outside of
Columbia Missouri do you know what
happened to him
the person on the phone is Lindley
renick she's explaining how she just
found the dead body of her husband 29
year old Ben renick on the floor
surrounded by containers of snakes
when I went to the scene where my
brother's body was found Lily was
outside crying hysterically and she was
in distress something was obviously
wrong you know what happened no so he's
not breathing at all
does it look like he's been shot yeah
maybe no he got killed by a snake I used
to be happy now please you have to
imagine
how intense slash bizarre the scene was
I don't understand you have an anaconda
where's it at
I know it's difficult right now but we
need to make sure nobody else gets hurt
what is it they still sick Ben had
become one of the leading people in the
world of snakes specifically breeding
snakes and he had a building that was
just stuffed with these things
is there a blood trade leading to him
nothing something got him the paramedic
said there's a bike mark on him so watch
your ass one of the most striking things
about the scene is the deputies walking
into this environment and they're
holding shotguns they're afraid that
they're going to get attacked by a snake
do we have anybody we could call to
deal with an anaconda
I'm gonna kill her we see we see it good
good
I prefer it that way Sam assumed that
these snakes had killed his brother due
to the types of injuries but of course
that wasn't the case at all
the corner when he walks into the room
and he sees men's body
he's thinking that there's something odd
because there's a tremendous pool of
blood and then he happens to glance over
and he notices on the Shelf
a spent bullet casing he knew that this
was something other than a snake bite
Ben had been shot multiple times
now investigators are dealing with a
whole different kind of scenario this
was no longer an accident but a murder
we couldn't have imagined a single
person on the earth that would want to
hurt Ben
and obviously we were wrong
I know you've talked to a handful of
other people today
about how your day went but if you want
to go ahead and walk us through it
Lindley renick is brought in to speak
with investigators she may be the key to
figuring out who could have done this to
Ben
you're watching the facility
and I called them
investigators then question whether this
could have been a family dispute turned
deadly is there any family issues
um like between Gammon
yeah their mom passed away and then
their dad shot himself then and I
actually own all of the property my
parents had fought for years decades to
keep that farm my mother had died there
my father died there my brother had died
there Sam kind of basically just went to
bend and he was like you need to give me
half of the property
then his wife sent been an iMessage that
was basically just kind of like
thank you you guys are greedy all you
care about is money and then
everything's just kind of hard over
there police looked at Ben's Brother Sam
as an investigator you look at who is
going to gain the most by killing
someone have you developed any kind of a
there is to what do you think happened
I immediately I took a polygraph I was
at work when he was murdered it wasn't
hard to disprove me do you know what
happened tonight
[Applause]
that's the question everyone wants
answered what happened that Summer
Afternoon coming up police may get some
answers as another possible suspect
comes into the mix
well and I dated for a while
[Music]
in June 2017 the body of Ben renick is
found by his wife Lindley renick on the
floor of his snake breeding facility in
Montgomery County Missouri initially
thought to be killed by a snake
authorities soon realized they're
dealing with a murder as Ben was shot to
death Lindley meets with investigators
several times and she shares a startling
confession
relationship
relationships I haven't been talking
anymore or did you have a relationship
Eric he's my marketing rep Lindley the
owner of a spa admits she's been
unfaithful in her marriage she had had
multiple fares it's estimated that
Lindley had at least two lovers in
addition to her husband maybe even a
third But Eric is not the only other man
in lindley's life
Michael Humphrey was another uh
interesting character in this rather
bizarre tale Michael is lindley's
ex-boyfriend
Michael and I dated for a while he's a
client I actually used to work on
do you know anything about business
I know that the news said that there was
an intruder
had to be made with a gun
he had a weird way that you met back up
I think you can agree with that yeah
she had reached out to him
and it's it's hard to understand why
I think I'm just going to lay it all out
for you I think you have some
involvement with this maybe she saw
utility in Michael the first time they
came by it was just like they wanted me
to look at installing some stereo stuff
in her friend's car or whatever I think
it was the next time that Lynn came by
she said that she was having some
different issues with her significant
other she started by letting him know
that she was planning on divorcing Ben
and that Ben had abused her she said he
reviews her like that I guess she wanted
me to go with her out there to talk him
in
because she said she can't leave via the
Facebook messages between uh Ben and
Lindley we learned that she complained
that Ben sexually assaulted her at night
while she was asleep there was a message
where Ben seemed to apologize for doing
so anyone that knew Ben
uh knew the kind of person that he was
the accusations that she proposed were
preposterous she had come down here for
a reason
she's looking for some way to get out of
the situation that she was in Mike she's
got other guys in her life they're all
married with kids they're all family
guys with jobs they're all the same kind
of guy
you're the outliers
no killer
after some back and forth Humphrey does
end up admitting he was at the snake
facility when Ben was killed he tried to
hand me a gun and I kind of just showed
it back I would walk up inside and all
of a sudden Josh rang I duck like this
and I looked back up she still got the
gun out like this I turned around and
ran through the door Michael Humphrey
was drawn into this Bob Lindley perhaps
just to Aid her in the death of Ben
perhaps in order to cover it up or
perhaps to put the blame all on him it's
a good question to ask what is lindley's
involvement and where does her
involvement began in his end or vice
versa I truly believe that she was the
one to pull the trigger we had so many
collaborative Witnesses and they were
still not able to finally say that she
was the one to pull the trigger but is
Michael Humphrey telling the truth of
what actually happened coming up Lindley
points the finger in a different
direction there had been this back and
forth between Michael and Lindley so
confusion Reigns it's up to the police
to kind of sort this out
[Music]
I told you at the beginning of the day
that we would both know at the end of
the day whether you had any involvement
in this whatsoever
it's summer 2017 and Missouri officials
are investigating the mysterious murder
of 29 year old Ben renick he was
initially thought to have been killed by
a snake at his reptile breeding facility
but it was soon realized he had actually
been shot eight times Ben's wife Lindley
the owner of a local spa is
investigators number one suspect but
another man in lindley's life her old
flame Michael Humphrey is also believed
to be involved after months of
investigating Lindley investigators try
something else there was something there
that gave the police pause with her and
they did in fact put her on a polygraph
okay how do you think you did
[Music]
the results of the polygraph showed that
you failed the test
we did everything we could to support
her after the murder we started seeing
some red flags right away and so did the
highway patrol I don't think he was a
church there is a big difference but
between standing and finding somebody
and pulling the trigger
[Music]
I know you did the highway patrol is a
really good idea of what had happened
things started coming together and it
was ugly picture
amid the interview it becomes apparent
there's something else going on in
lindley's life that raises even more
suspicions
the band was going to shut it down
problem was was that the spa was not
doing quite so well certainly not as
well as Ben's business they had no idea
how dead you were yeah he did not know
that you were 15 to 20
he was going to find out she had been
mismanaging the finances at her business
he was probably going to find out about
the Affairs as well and that would have
been a deal killer for him some will say
that lonely was cold-hearted and she
needed some money and she saw that as an
opportunity to get some life insurance
we know
he had just taken down a one million
dollar insurance policy on himself he
had just sold his biggest transaction
for about 1.2 million dollars the farm
was in his name solely and when he died
it went directly to Lindley I'm seeking
answers for you
investigators have a pretty good idea of
who's behind Ben's murder
yet there's still not quite enough
evidence to charge anyone so the
investigation goes cold when we return
will investigators finally learn the
truth about Ben renick's death my
information is out of the horse's mouth
and by the horse you mean Lindley
[Music]
I didn't have anything to do but it is
harder there is so much circumstantial
evidence against you in this case it's
mind-boggling
in the summer of 2017 29 year old Ben
renick is murdered at his snake breeding
facility in Central Missouri his wife
Lindley renick and her one-time
boyfriend Michael Humphrey are both
suspected of being involved but there's
not enough to charge the pair
however in January 2020 there's an
unexpected break in the investigation
when someone comes forward with
case-changing information ever since I
found this stuff out it's been in my
head every day man Lindley was having an
affair with Brandon Blackwell
came forward to the police and that
really got the ball rolling I think them
was getting to the point where he was
going to leave her she was sucking money
out of them for her business and this
relationship didn't wasn't going well I
think they did suspect her the entire
time but he told the police that he
believed that Lindley had killed her
husband her and
Michael Humphrey the drove to the farm
she walks in with the gun and she just
shoots him a bunch of times and leaves
and Michael kept a gun supposedly to
dispose of and investigators also had
Ashley Shaw lindley's employee
cut to the chase you have been
implicated in being a part of Ben's
death so it's basically you're either on
team Lindley or you're on team Missouri
and team lindley's going to jail who
became a cooperating witness for the
government you had the walls kind of
start to close in on her it was kind of
like a game of musical chairs and
eventually Lindley was the only one left
standing after three years of
investigating in more than a dozen
interviews Lindley renick and Michael
Humphrey are both charged with
first-degree murder and armed criminal
action there were moments where I lost
hope but there was a lot of relief
knowing that she was finally going to be
held accountable we didn't even see it
coming vid had no idea we had led a wolf
into our family and not even known it
that cost us dearly renick and Humphrey
are tried separately with Humphrey's
trial ending in a guilty verdict for
first-degree murder but after the trial
he makes a deal his conviction was
mitigated down to murder in the second
degree so lindley's problem here was
that the people that assisted her in
committing crimes lined up against her
and they ended up becoming Witnesses
against her at trial she's been running
this spot it's been open about a year or
so and it's not doing well and
ultimately he gives her a few months so
literally who's offered the sole
beneficiary of the one million life
insurance policy on fenrennic decides
Chicago Illinois divorce she's gonna
kill him there was tremendous financial
gain to be had on the part of Lindley
certainly the prosecution proved that
through financial records text messaging
it finally culminates in Ben's death did
she discuss with you divorcing that yes
but she had told you that that wasn't an
option for her right did she present to
you or talk to you about a different
manner of handling or resolving her
marital issues yes she asked if
um I could help her with murdering him
well needs a passenger seat slides the
gun my gun I was freaking out a little
bit
because it's my God
you believed it had just been used to do
what to shoot somebody the defense must
present a strong enough case to convince
the jury that it wasn't Lindley and part
of that was pointing the finger at
someone else they make the very very
unfortunate decision
to
ask Michael Humphrey to go with London
about a divorce well let me run it does
not know is that in the seven years
since she broke up with Michael Humphrey
Michael Humphrey has graduated into a
violent
Mass addicted career Criminal you've got
two primary suspects that are pointing
the fingers at one another you told the
police on 116 lenly did this right all
by herself right you told them that
because you knew the police suspected
Bentley had done this and you were
trying to feed them a story that you
thought that they would believe correct
them that's because that's what happened
I think the defense did a good job with
what they had to work with and what they
had to work with was chaos we were
confident going into the trial that the
prosecution had everything they needed
but we are aware that it just takes one
juror and she was definitely gonna put
on a show she was good at that kind of
thing she was too good at it if you
asked me and who better to tell her own
story than Lindley renick herself
Michael turned around
and I saw a gun in his hands and then I
heard shots
wearing out and I ran outside and
everything just went numb lindley's
argument ultimately was that Humphrey
killed Ben do you regret ever getting
back in contact with Michael Humphrey
yes
did you kill Ben renick I did not kill
my husband did you ask Michael Humphrey
to kill Ben renick no she knew what she
was doing when she got in that stand
she stared directly at the drawers
she wore that cross that didn't belong
on her neck
and tried to portray herself as as
weak
but was it enough to convince the jury
after more than 11 hours of
deliberations a jury came back with a
surprising verdict as to first-degree
murder
jury find the defendant Lindley renick
guilty of murder in the second degree I
hope the 12 jurors never forgive
themselves for what they've done it was
an absolutely unjust verdict it is a
judgment sentence of this court that you
be confined in an institution for a
period of 13 years on count one and
three years on count two Lindley renick
is sentenced to 16 years in prison
Lindley has a parole hearing scheduled
for
2034 and she is also certainly going to
get credit for the time that she has
served so she could potentially
walk out of prison at that time
you're awful lucky ma'am you're going to
get out in your 40s and my 40s weren't
too bad
I just hope you don't kill again she'd
Rob the world of a brilliant mind
somebody that was well respected in his
little community and not just locally
but throughout the world and sadly
you've got a child that's growing up
fatherless as a result of their mother
but the battle for Ben renick's family
isn't over she had isolated my brother's
children immediately after the murder
they were able to transfer custody from
Lindley to her sister they actually told
the children that I was the one that
murdered them even after the arrest
we have still not seen them one day not
one day since the murder nothing life is
fair
but some decisions could be not just
selfish but cruel
they're not returning my brother's
remains and keeping those children in
the dark like they have is Unforgivable
at the time of this recording Lindley
renick has officially dropped her appeal
of her conviction and by all accounts
she's going to serve out the remainder
of her term in prison
it's interesting thinking about where
this investigation began in a reptile
facility because it turns out the only
real snake in this case was the woman
who wanted her husband dead
that's all we have for you here on Prime
crime thanks so much for joining us and
until next time stay safe
[Music]